so we spend a lot of time pounding on
the democratic party and individual
democrats on this show but the truth is
we'll be totally honest we need a sane
democratic party in america if we're
going to continue democrats and
republicans will always disagree on
specific solutions but the key is this
both parties have to have the same goal
improving the country and the lives of
the individual americans who live here
as long as you have that the rest is
just a policy debate that's the way it's
been for centuries that's what we need
to return to
and there is we're happy to say some
evidence on the margins that some people
in the democratic party are beginning to
realize this here's an example example
abigail spanberger is a pretty liberal
actually member of congress from the
richmond suburbs of virginia but last
week after her party was crushed in that
state she said some true and obvious
things about why her party might be in
trouble here's part of it nobody elected
biden to be fdr she told the new york
times they elected him to be normal and
stop the chaos we were so willing to
take seriously a global pandemic but
we're not willing to say yeah inflation
is a problem and supply chain is a
problem and we don't have enough workers
in our workforce we gloss over that and
only like to admit problems in spaces
that we dominate
so it's not a partisan point to note
that that's just true it's absolutely
true these aren't radical observations
they're really obvious
but on the left right now it takes
courage to say that and as americans we
want to do whatever we can to support
people who think like this regardless of
what party they're in
tulsi gabbard is one of those people and
so we're always happy to talk to her she
joins us tonight congresswoman thanks so
much for coming on it does seem like
as long as everybody can agree that you
want to make the lives of the people who
live here better
then you can't kind of go too far off
course
do you think that that you know
everyone's sort of waking up to that are
we moving toward remembering that or no
i i think that really is the critical
thing here is that when we have
democrats and republicans in positions
of leadership of course they're going to
be disagreements on different issues or
how we approach solving the problems of
the american people but so long as the
goal is the same the goal being hey we
want to do what is best for the american
people and our country then we know that
progress is possible and that's where we
we absolutely need more than just sane
leaders because the problem is bigger
than just insanity the problem that we
have now is leaders who are so willing
to manipulate the american people to
further their own selfish political
interests or money or power or whatever
it is and we see this very clearly in in
how everything in our country is being
racialized that this is an intentional
strategy to tear us apart based on the
color of our skin because they think
that there's some political gain to be
had from it and they don't care at all
about the destruction that they leave
in their wake and this is what we as
voters need to reject and choose leaders
who do put the american people in our
country first who share that objective
from both political parties yeah that
the example you just gave which is at
the center of so much of the rhetoric is
such an obvious dead end it's you know
the the end point of that is is violence
and division everyone can tell
you've got to think that there are
people in the democratic party who get
that
are there
i sure hope so unfortunately as
uh we see too often
more and more democrats are pushing this
this racialization
they are pushing uh more fomenting of
anger and hatred and divisiveness uh
that that really is destroying us it's
causing more suffering and more harm to
the american people and the fabric of
our country and undermining these values
that our country was founded on
i think this is where when you look at
the election that happened in
virginia you saw terry mcauliffe
represented that fomenting of
divisiveness this racialization and
virginia voters rejected that and again
regardless of political party this is
what i hope we see more of in the
country that voters take a stand and
make a choice democrat or republican we
want leaders who sincerely care for our
people and care for our country and who
will serve
putting those interests of service above
self
man it's just so inspiring to hear that
and i i gotta think
that their the vast majority of
americans agree with what you what you
just said no matter what they look like
or who they voted for so thank you for
saying it chelsea gabbard former member
of congress from hawaii